last but not the least it's a pleasure
to have florence zakala
to give a last presentation of of today
florian doesn't need introduction uh to
this crowd of course
uh gave a very nice boot camp talk
uh late august and uh
the only thing i will remind and he as
flora and lenka would like to remind
others is that they
are moved to epfl and happy to host lots
of visitors and i plan to take advantage
of that as soon as
uh coffee situation uh permits that so
with that said
uh the floor is yours
thank you thank you uh i assume everyone
can hear me well
all right let's start um yeah thank you
for organizing this
and uh yes it's it's a pleasure to to to
feel connected to all of you
and to listen to the talk and uh i hope
we will uh
you know meet again in real life
soon enough all right let's go so i want
to discuss uh
phase retrieval today um so the problem
doesn't really need the introduction but
i'm gonna give one anyway
so you have a vector x which you don't
know
and what you know is instead is the
modulus
of the projection of this vector so you
have a matrix a
you multiply it by the vector and you
take the absolute value
you know if your math if this is a
complex problem or
you take
the modulus if it is a real one and then
you have
a measurement so you are given y
a and you try to reconstruct x
all right uh so um what i want to
discuss here is slightly more specific
and in the spirit of many problems in
this workshop is what happens if you are
doing random
measurement and in particular random
projections so here the matrix a
is chosen randomly so let's assume that
a is a random matrix
pick your favorite one iid matrices
with a gaussian coefficient or maybe a
random rotation matrix
subsample dft there are many interesting
problems
now x instead would be at least in the
first part of the talk
just a normalized vector okay so think
about x sample uniformly on the sphere
and i will discuss more interesting or
more challenging
situations on x later on
and so these are the questions you want
to know okay how many
observations are how many observations
does one need to recover
uh x better at the random guess at the
recovery
perfectly but strong recovery and
what algorithms i'm sure you use right
and of course i'm going to discuss
the i dimensional limit when both m
number of measurement and d the
dimension of x goes to infinity together
with a fixed fraction
all right so let me uh essentially spoil
the fun and give you the answer
right now so for weak recovery in order
to beat the random guess
these are the answers okay it's easier
to state them
with this notation where the real case
is beta equal one
complex case is beta equal to
so uh if your matrix is just iid
gaussian
the answer is known uh for real and in
fact also for complex case thanks to
this
very nice work by marco andrea and
let's tell you just you need m over d to
be larger than beta over two
okay so one half for real and one for
complex for random orthogonal matrices
or you know
random rotation matrix if you want well
gentle is also known and it was uh due
to this work in the team of aryan
malechi
and it's actually harder you know it's m
of a d
is leisure on one plus beta over two so
it's actually a more difficult problem
so one of the first contribution we had
was to look at
a very generic set of random matrices
right so our matrices are
u sigma v where u and v are random
rotation matrices
and c mac cinema so these are the set of
rotationally invariant matrices if you
want
and we have this result that m already
should be legendary one plus beta over
two
and we have escalation here uh in which
indeed what you see that it just depends
on the distribution of eigenvalues
that you find and if all your
eigenvalues are one you come back to uh
to the sensors if you plug martian
coopers2 you will come back to s1 and
let's generalize the situation
this is all uh noiseless models
there's not all this is noiseless yes
yeah now what about the strong recovery
and
here it has to be noiseless if you want
to give an answer
and it's actually uh simpler to state
it's very trivial actually what you need
if you
if you want to have a vanishing error
is m d larger than beta so larger than
one in the real case
measurement two is the complex case and
that's interesting because that's
exactly what you would guess naively by
counting
argument so again so that was
shown for the real case here for
gaussian matrices
in this paper they show it for
unitary matrices and we actually
generalize this to
these and sample now to be a bit more
precise
that is our main result in this case
which of course i will not you know
discuss the equation but essentially uh
it's a proof of a replica result so
there is that kind of replicaf energy
that appears all the time in
in statistical phoenix literature so you
have this complex function
that you need to uh to extremize if you
manage to extremize it
well replicator will tell you that the
minimum misconduct you should get in
this problem is one minus q x when q
x is um one of the elements you have to
extremize over actually you have to take
a soup here
so we obtained this result with
statistical mechanics method and then we
managed to prove them
is an interpolation method and
in fact we tried to prove these results
for all matrices that were rotationally
invariant and we could not do this
but we managed to prove it for all
matrices of the form wb
where w is gaussian and b is arbitrary
okay so it's still kind of a very large
set of matrices which is larger than
just the iid gaussian that we use and in
particular it includes all correlated
quotients
right so that means that for all these
matrices we can actually
tell what is going on with the complex
and really phase retrieval and also
compute the minimal musical error
so let's forget this ugly formula and
look what it actually means
this is what it means if you increase
the number of measurements
and you have a gaussian matrix this is a
complex case
all right so your error is one not
better on the random guess until you
meet the weak recovery threshold which
is an enemy
over this one then it decay and then
exactly at two you should expect to jump
to the royal
okay for orthogonal matrices and that
was shown by the group of malikitel
actually the weak recovery is equal to
the trans recovery and transition is
exactly at 2.
okay so this is what should happen if
you are able to
to compute the minimal mean square error
but of course i didn't tell you
how to do it this is a statistical or
information theoretical
prediction the question is
what about efficient algorithm in this
case okay how would you do it in
practice
now for those who know me you would not
be surprised of course i tried me such
nothing
what else uh we have now a very good
control about
what approximately such passing and
message passing and bp is doing
in fact for the kind of problem
discussing we have something called
vamp which is vector approximate message
passing
it can handle all these rotationally
environment matrices
and it has been written for phase
retrieval uh invest work
so we can just use our standard
technology run this algorithm and see
what's going on
and we can analyze uh its results uh
with uh the state evolution techniques
okay
and what do we find that we find what
you would expect i guess if you're an
imp well imp is doing a good job
these are the points these are the
simulations except
well if you zoom close to the
information therapy threshold you uh
you see that it's not exactly what quite
we expect again you can
compare you know with the state
evolution techniques and
if you zoom here well
you see that there is this very small
region where
you have the information theoretic
transaction at two while i go with
meekly
you find something good you know 2.1 or
something
and you have the same kind of phenomenon
for the orthogonal matrices
okay so this is what we expect we have
discussed this thing
many times without the difference
between uh
what what's easy and our transition yes
what is the prior here
like oh this is just a x on the sphere
just a
and for the simulations you just use
some x random on the sphere
yes but actually it doesn't really
matter because being on this field is
just a constraint on the norm so
as long as you pick a vector which is
you know not correlated with the matrix
it's basically the same all the time
thanks
yeah all right
now here i have been lying to you
uh because i told you that the analysis
of imp
you can do it with state evolution is
that actually quite
true in this problem because well
because there is a symmetry between you
know plus six and minus six
and because of this when you try to
understand rigorously what is going on
with imp
if you run state evolution you should
start exactly at a gas
which does not break the symmetry but if
you don't break the symmetry imp will
stay there
now random initialization work in
practice this is how you obtain this
plot
but if you just initialize imp randomly
then your state evolution uh analysis is
not regardless anymore
so it's a bit annoying that you know
this problem is
and it is there as far as as we know
uh and one way around it if you want to
study um
perhaps more rigorously what's going on
with weak recovery is to look to
spectral methods and in fact it is
something that was done uh
uh one or two years ago and in the
series of work first by uh
andrea and marco and then in a group of
you you
all right so when i think about the
spectral method for any problem on which
i use
message passing techniques i always
think
about two ways to derive them okay one
way
it's essentially the one we used back
then with chris
joe and alan and pan and lenka and
el cannon in 2014 when we know we
linearize bp
you just linearize the message passing a
recursion and that's what leads to the
non-backtracking matrix okay so that's
one way
you can do it you can write it in fact
uh you can gener
you know not only you can do it but it
was done uh it was first done i think in
this paper
and if you do this you obtain indeed a
matrix which is here it's actually a
non-symmetric
m times n matrix so it can you know blow
up if you have many measure or not
but you know it's a well-defined problem
and then you can try to analyze what's
going on with frontal matrix derivatives
now the different techniques which i
like a lot is to
not to focus on message passing but to
focus on what message passing is solving
and actually what message pressing is
doing
you know bp what it is doing is to try
to evaluate the better scenario uh
actually imp is trying to obtain to to
to solve the tap
energy if you want uh if you are using
these matrices which are not id gaussian
there is another term which is a left
kafka energy so the placeholder energy
energies
you know there is this thing called the
plaschka energy which is a systematic
correction of tap
whenever your matrix is not iad gaussian
okay and it's it's a very nice uh you
know there is deep connection between
plasca and kikuchi followers who know
and i'm not fully understanding that i
think there is room for connection
so instead of trying to linearize the
message passing i can say well you know
the massage passing is trying to
find an extrema of a free energy so
maybe what i should do is to be at the
you know trivial extrema and to look at
the ocean
and the asian of the free energy will
tell me good direction to go
okay that is something we actually did
back then for community detection with
ala sadie and lancasterova
and interestingly if you do this you
have a matrix
which you find here which is i don't
know much simpler it's n times n
it's symmetric and so it looks much
nicer
and it has this form now that's
interesting
uh because that's exactly the kind of
object that was studied in this paper by
uh
on the inventor by lulu etel in fact
what they did was to study a matrix
of this form okay that was linear
combination of
the matrix element with a function tau
applied to the measurement y and what
they did in these two works the first
time they had proposed vest and then he
found
one form of tau that was good enough to
find
the correct transition and then
invest second work ulu optimized over
the whole set of function and try to
find the best function
and interestingly if you try to duress
you try to find the best function
what they found uh you know much before
us
was exactly what is directly given to
you if you just compute the action of
the free energy so i think this is nice
uh and it's probably saying that
yes there is something that i understand
in this thing i mean in in our paper
actually we we do both calculations and
actually we show that they are
equivalent
i mean there is some yes simple
matrix transformation yeah yes but in
your paper you are looking to uh gush
and
uh yeah yeah yeah yeah sure i mean yeah
yeah i'm just like
you know the two men i know i know i
will go
you're spoiling the next slide
yes you're right okay but so if you
yes okay so first remark
uh and remark two what is interesting uh
here
is that if you look at the expression
you find here
well the only place where the spectrum
appears
is here for these uh averages so
you actually do not depend on the
spectrum
uh in uh in uh in your spectral method
you don't need to know the spectrum you
need to know the matrix but
you know so that means that this form
which is the one
obtained in the second paper when it was
really optimized
uh it suggests that it should be
universal and but
actually that's the best function
whatever the spectrum is
and in fact we are going to see that
this is true uh
and i'm almost going back to andrea so
you know what andrea said is also true
in
you know beyond gaussian matrices so
this is what happens
for method a okay so it's a
non-symmetric matrix so if you
diagonalize it
you are you know you have the complexion
values and you have interesting
phenomena but
at some point you have one eigenvalue
that goes out and that is informative
and what is very interesting but there
is a second ligand value which is
informative which is here
okay these two even though it is
informative of course it's harder to
obtain this one
the iteration now when we do the plefka
eshen or uelus method if you want
uh you know it's something very similar
you have
at the exact same point you have one
eigenvalue that goes out and which is
informative
now what andrea uh
showed for gaussian matrices is still
true here
and there is an equivalence between the
two and what is interesting is that this
guy here
doesn't correspond to the guy that goes
outside but to this one
and the same for you know this guy
correspond to this guy
so somehow the plafka is missing the
leading value here
so this is connected with the fact that
you know the way you derive it you're
not
completely spent you know looking at all
the negative direction
but that's what we found now it looks
like maybe this is bad
but interestingly you will see that this
second value here
has a much better overlap with the
planted true but this one
which is surprising but this is true and
i don't have an explanation for it
so there is a connection between the two
and this is you know
the kind of thing we find so if you have
complex question matrices and
you you you applied in this method uh
this is a transition so this is a method
of
the first method by andrea which pick up
exactly the right transition
and now if you use the method of ua
which is the one where you
further optimize the function to find
the best one
and it also corresponds to the tap clef
creation
here this curve to a lower error
interestingly if you use this method
which i thought would be the best
naively at least when you learn a step
you know
well it seems that you have something
better than random here but this is just
random punctuation so
it's okay uh it's systematically
actually worse than
the two of them
all right so i still think this is
interesting uh and of course then you
can generalize those two matrices which
are not gaussian
and the interesting thing is that then
you know this uh asian matrices
don't need to be adapted you don't need
to further optimize it's always giving
you a very good overlap
and that's the correct transition all
the time
so i found it nice okay these are other
examples for
our matrices so i found it nice uh that
you know it's not a new discovery we
knew about the spectral method but it's
kind of nice to see that
they do what we expect them to do you
know if we derive
them from first principle of what we
believe a good algorithm should be
we find them back and this is nice and
you can generalize generalize them to
other problems such as
poisson noise and so on and so forth
okay that's what i wanted to tell you
for for the first part i still want to
tell you something fun
about this problem
which is uh okay and what's connected to
some of the question i had
what happens if we have a better prior
forex
okay so of course one thing that come to
mind in sparsity
everyone has been looking to vest in
fact i was looking to to exactly this
problem a few years ago and
we wrote this paper with jean-barbie
nicolas
when we looked exactly at this long
story short
about the kind of phase diagram you have
for real phase phase retrieval
for sparsity so you know
your number of measurements with respect
to the dimension which is no p
i'm sorry uh should be you know the
end of the p should be larger than row
so you know the number of measurements
should be larger than sparsity otherwise
it's impossible
what's interesting you have a hard phase
here and like i showed this during the
boot camp and you see that the art face
stop at zero five
and so this means that it's really
impossible to compress something uh in
this case because
you know you don't have good algorithm
that works here and another phenomenon
which is interesting uh which i don't
think anyone picked up but i think it's
a funny
remark is that what we found is that
weak recovery itself is hard
like here we don't know if any algorithm
if you know if n of p is smaller than
0.5
i mean i actually what i can say is imp
doesn't work doesn't beat a random guess
and so i strongly suspect that
you know any uh sdp relaxation of
criminal grace will have
the same problem but i've never seen
anyone looking at this i think it's it's
an interesting
thing but okay so this is for sparsity
okay but that was this is so 2015
right now we're in 2020 and it's all
about deep learning so what happens
if you use more complex prior and of
course this day you can do a very
interesting prayer say that you know
x is an image you will say find i will
train the
set of neural networks on the set of all
faces and then i will
have a gan or normalizing flow whatever
you want and you you could generate
a very good prayer so you say you know x
has been generated
starting from random vector z and then
it went through a neural network and it
was like this
now if x is generated by that that west
network and i do
something like uh uh retrieval how hard
is it
all right i have no clue okay it's
really hard to analyze
everything because of course if you
learn these w's
i don't know to analyze this one thing
we can do
of course is to say well you know
life's too short let's assume that all
the w's are random
now then we can analyze everything okay
then
it comes back to things that we can
analyze and it
generalize very well some of the things
we can do uh i will go you know i just
want to
show you for instance how you can
compute the mutual information
for such a problem so again for the
sample problem
we knew to do it so if you have x you
get y
that's actually what we got for the
mutual information okay this is entropy
of y
okay it's an extremization of a function
okay and
with a bit of rewriting you can show
that this is the extremization of the
entropy
of x plus some noise plus some function
which
has not a nice face
okay so but the trick is the following
if you have a two layer problem so x now
has been generated by
one layer neural network with a random
matrix you can heuristically derive the
solution like this
okay so this generated x and then from x
you get y by uh
this phase rate level
okay forget about z let's assume that
the formula we had before is still valid
even though x is not iid now it's
complicated
problem okay so then that's the solution
except now we need to evaluate the
entropy of
x but since x is not iid
this is not entirely trivial to do
fair enough but if you look at this and
you remember what x
is well this is the entropy of a
variable which is square root of m phi
of w z
but that's in itself is a generalized
linear model it is the kind of
exactly the problem we solve here so you
can take this formula
and plug it there and
putting everything together you have now
a
formula in which you have to optimize
over well
twice as many are viable okay and you
can repeat this that kind of lego
principle add infinitum
and uh we actually proofread grossly
that this is true at least for three
layers and it's probably true for more
layers but then it's a bit harder the
trouble is to prove the existence of
the free energy but you know except for
that the proof goes through
and uh you know the theoristic
derivation is telling you how
this thing goes together all right and
of course you can do the same kind of
thing with imp
i won't go into the detail just want to
advertise a
distribution that we put on github that
can do all this problem
and it's very versatile now
what is going on then so it's very
interesting
once you put structure in your prior
it changes everything now that's the for
instance
what happened if x is not iid uh with
sparsity but
rollu of a matrix w times z and z is
gaussian
okay now if you look at the number of
freedom it's not anymore given by
sparsity but probably
by the size of z so that's the number of
latent variable if you will
and now this is your new phase diagram
and this is to be compared when
with the one you had when your only
information was sparsity
and you see that it changed quite a lot
you know with
uh you know from here to here
you have changed things first of all
your art phase is much smaller suddenly
you can do compressed sensing
and you know that's not surprising but
the effect is striking you know
generative model are really really
really uh helpful
here not only in terms of complete
you know statistic information but also
algorithmically
and another interesting point is the
following one what happens if you are
using
a deeper neural network still random
well you know you see that you start to
converge
uh you know you basically kill here that
phase
with depth and here you know it also
goes to zero
it seems to go to zero but much more
slowly not clear actually i think there
is still a gap
and invest paper poll hand and tal
actually designed
one special scaling in which they could
completely
destroy the heart phase uh i mean it was
of course a bit made up but
it was very interesting that you could
do it in principle uh for such problems
okay and i think this is interesting and
it shows that we can start to analyze uh
correlated data
and that you know good priors uh
you know can reduce drastically uh
statistical to computational gaps
all right um almost my last slide uh
there are many more generalizations to
what i have presented
even in the second part again you know i
discussed phase vectors the theory is
not limited to phase that evolved any
generalized model will do
we did it also for matrix and transfer
factorization you can also adapt
spectral method to use deep prior that
give you a
you know a clever spectral method of
okay i'm really done and i want to thank
my collaborator and students and
postdocs on this project
and as uh dimitri
said uh you know we are looking for
talented postdoc
student if you like the view and if you
want to go in epfl write me a name
okay thanks very much florent uh let's
think
uh and let's open for questions
if if questions feel free to post it on
on the q a or or just go live
i made a mistake i i lost your face
i don't know what i did exactly i love
the screen
we can see you yeah i can see you but
you know i'm a disadvantage but that's
fine
i don't know if nobody has i have a
small question
so there is the so you you
you have results for these orthogonal
ensembles
and then uh do you know i i didn't
follow this are there any progress being
made about
uh coded diffraction patterns that is
essentially partial fourier transform
because that is a more realistic
model yes yes very good so uh
i think that
there is a student of ariane who might
be listening right now i don't remember
the name maybe
there is actually proved a result
for random sampled fourier
so in the case of x being gaussian
i think so yes so that is nice right
it's actually the only result i know for
fully deterministic matrices and so
this is nice it's restricted to x
taken on this field but you know but
still remarkable
and it's the only one i know that goes
beyond
[Music]
just random matrix like the
there's a question from prasad prasad if
if you want to go live and
ask your question uh please go ahead if
not i will
i found a way to to to to find you back
it's good
okay prasad you
okay i'll i'll read his question what is
the easiest prior
ie are there national priors under which
the phase retrieval has no hard face
like like natural ones
i don't think so but there is a matrix
for which it has no art phrase
now there is a way to design uh so if
you take product of a matrix
which is a product of two gaussians
and you select uh aspect ratio to i
think it was one i'm not so sure but we
write it in the paper so there is one
aspect ratio
uh in which when your measurement matrix
is a product of two gaussians
that entirely kill that phase and uh
that was surprising to us
uh so that's and that was you know
otherwise uh no i don't think
i have seen uh you know natural sample
prior for which
there was no advice at all
if you make if you make all the entries
of of the prior integer valid
and make it noiseless then there is a
sample size of one that is needed
and and it's in and it's always an easy
phrase
okay yeah fair enough
i i'm not i'm not sure it's natural but
uh
maybe that's an example i see
go ahead florent you were saying
something no no no no
i'm listening uh sit hunt
i know you can go live you want to ask
her a question
uh sure yeah so uh actually i was
curious about
um the two ways of getting special
methods that you
mentioned one was linear amp the other
was the hessian so i guess in particular
the question i was wondering about
is whether there's some kind of like
determinant identity
relating the two just just because at
least for the
analog of beta free energy that's like
this formula
yes yes yes now they should be connected
uh of course uh
you know but uh for instance for
community detection we are communicating
they are connected through yeah
formula uh in the work of andrea and
marco actually you know
they showed some connection now
i i'm not fully understanding exactly
uh everything now because you know this
is
slightly more involved because um
now it's just vamp and i don't you know
it's and
it's like you know and also there are
many ways to do the linearization
so i think there should be a one-to-one
correspondence that
must be true now when you do um
you know the linearization there are
many ways to linearize you know you say
okay now i take fixed point of
everything i perturb here
and maybe i will assume this guy will
not change and so
some you know for instance inp
or vamp actually do not have uh n
degree of freedom it has 2n plus 2n
degree of freedom
so if you really compute the full
perturbation matrix it's really
complicated so you say okay fine i will
look to this
subset and this is what i have done in
both cases
okay it's not the true asian it's not
the true perturbation matrices
so it's you know and then you have this
complicated object and you say okay
let's try to prove that this
this thing has the same again values and
and to try to get the robust formula
so i don't know yet how to do this
totally uh you know in a systematic way
for his uh
invest problem uh but at least i know
that if you do it that way
the second you know the eager values
inside
the bulk uh for method one correspond to
the
value outside the ball for method two
um but it's probably not the only way to
do it and there is probably
you know more way to think about it
yes sorry yeah i mean perhaps if i can
add a comment
yeah there is if you look at uh you know
our paper there is a
relation via determinant of your
connection
oh good okay something is something i
don't remember exactly that is something
relatively simple
thank you there's a question by you hong
kong is there a version of the replica
symmetric formula for the base risk
you showed for id matrix x for rotation
invariant x
for the base risk of which which
variable
for the rotate for when axis rotational
invariant
okay so that x is uh
is the vector or not uh the matrix i'm a
bit confused
right should be for the matrix uh yeah
i'm
trying to interpret the question myself
uh yes i
in fact i think this is essentially uh
the one i gave
here well you know
[Music]
oh yes so the answer is yes
there is one it's in our paper
now the question is is it a replica
formula or is it
can we prove it
so we know to compute the base risk
i think if x is a spherical
for almost all rotationally variant
matrices
if x is not spherical okay so let's say
that your vector is a
ghost bernoulli or something the proof
only works for
gaussian matrices i'm pretty sure the
formula is correct for australian
variant but i don't know to do it in
this case
i'm going to improve it
last question yeah go ahead
so um when i i first heard about this
problem from veit elser
who has these uh alternating projection
methods
and you know divide and conquer and adm
and that whole business uh
do we know anything about uh
the performance of those algorithms on
these random problems
is there any hope of analyzing them and
comparing them with these methods
does it make sense to linearize them et
cetera et cetera
uh you you really like this algorithm
right you keep asking this question
it's a it's a crazy kooky algorithm of
course
and it works well so okay two answers uh
first one
uh i have no idea about the divide and
conquer
second question actually when you run
vamp you know with vector opposite
message passing which is the same as
something you know it's the same as
something called the expectation
maximization and it turns the same at
what physicist is called plefka
and it's again the same as what
kabashima called adata
this algorithm is extremely similar to a
dmm
and indeed the way it works
is by solving you know things on one
side and then trying to solve on the
other side
and blah blah blah blah blah until you
converge
and when i'm saying it's very similar
it's more than very similar if you
do the map version of the algorithm you
know to minimize the cost function
you can show that they are exactly the
same
correspondence but don't those
algorithms also have this weird
um over damping that you know you will
cause the algorithm to fly away from
local minima and so on
well you know at least vamp works
but you know the thing which is
interesting between the difference
between vamp and idmm and everything
is that in you know this vector i mean
such pressing at each steps
you are kind of changing your the
constant of your idea in a way that
will help you converge and uh
you know that kind of help that kind of
thing
i mean i find it's nice that we start to
make connection with optimization
algorithm in fact we use this for
for for for studying over problems but
yeah it's not the place to discuss
but at least there is a connection here
and so that's interesting
any further questions
as we are slowly moving to the
canceled open set open problem sessions
so no further questions
let me suggest that we thank all three
speakers of
this morning and we will resume tomorrow
thank you all
and see you tomorrow